[Music]
there's one out getting thin
here are some BuzzFeed lists I saw
recently that I thought were a pretty
weak here's 17 moustaches that suspect
they're growing on a douche bag
they're not sure but how can they work
right in that guy's case yeah 14 Civil
War reenactors who prefer to die early
and catch some Z's for this one 18
photos of Vin Diesel with skinny arms
I love VIN like that look at this one
this is good 12 funeral DJ's just
killing it
oh please we all gotta go sixteen
cupcakes you stare that longer than you
should have eleven pugs that gave in and
got Botox he looks so happy
can't help it sixty-two beautiful
sunsets that have a better shot of being
elected president than Ted Cruz thirteen
apples that look like they're covered in
caramel but it's actually something much
worse
and no it's not applesauce 14 pots that
say they're friends with plenty of black
kettle's 19 new iPad pros that don't
know they'll only be used for pouring 27
pieces of trash that are about to be
sold on Etsy 7 cremation vessels that
don't take themselves too seriously
[Laughter]
that's what I want and II talked to my
wife five cat burglars who thought it
would be funny to use the litter box and
finally 37 celebrities who are great at
faking laughter
[Music]
I'm I'm number one
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please